Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Aber trotzdem dur. Aber Moll wäre eigentlich...
Moll wäre angemessen...
.wär angemessen, ne? Ja, heute wieder eine dystopische Sendung. Irgendwie bleibt uns das derzeit nicht so richtig erspart. Aber irgendwann eines Tages werden wir uns an diesen Tag erinnern und sagen, man kann sich auch wieder hocharbeiten. Das ist auch das Schöne an schlimmen Phasen. Also ich finde immer so persönliche Katastrophen und so weiter auch insofern immer eigentlich ganz angenehm, als dass es danach dann meistens einfach nur noch bergauf geht.
Ja, das dauert aber teilweise halt eine längere Zeit.
Naja, das war halt ein bisschen durchhaltend so. Da wird nicht alles in die Wiege gelegt. Ja, wie auch immer, 76. Ausgabe von Logbuch Netzpolitik. Wir begrüßen alle, die immer noch durchhalten und an die Zukunft glauben. Paar sind wohl noch über, obwohl man irgendwie auch schon so ein bisschen das Gefühl hat, dass es kippen auch alle irgendwie so mental so ein bisschen weg. Nicht zuletzt diese Gesellschaft. Darüber sollten wir vielleicht dann auch noch mal am Ende ein wenig reden.
Ja, die Vorkommnisse dieser Woche oder die Neuigkeiten dieser Woche, es ging ja der vergangenen Woche seit der letzten Sendung. Es ging los damit, dass der Lebenspartner von Glenn Greenwald auf der...
Der Ehemann übrigens.
Ehemann? Stimmt, ja klar, die sind verheiratet.
So ein Thema, was natürlich jetzt auf einmal auch mit so auf die Agenda kommt, obwohl es ja eigentlich keine Rolle spielen sollte, wieder so Geschmacksfärbung und so. Ich wusste es halt nicht.
Aber offensichtlich ist die da nicht wirklich interessiert, oder?
Nö, aber ich finde es jetzt mal relevant, dass sie quasi, also wir müssen ja vielleicht noch mal kurz zusammenfassen, sollte irgendjemand noch unterm Stein gewesen sein, was hier passiert ist. Also der Ehemann von Glenn Greenwald, dem Journalisten des Guardian, der diese ganzen Snowden-Dokumente in den letzten Monaten an die Öffentlichkeit getragen hat, der selber in Brasilien wohnt und da halt mit David Miranda. Dieser Miranda, der hat eine Reise angetreten nach Berlin, interessanterweise, weil irgendwie tummeln sich hier gerade alle Verfolgten. Hat man so den Eindruck, Deutschland scheint an der Stelle dann nach Moskau. Sozusagen der nächste sichere Hafen zu sein.
Die verfolgen ja nicht unbedingt, aber sagen wir mal so die engsten Vertrauten.
Na ja gut, ich meine, wenn man sich jetzt anschaut, was passiert ist, da ist schon Verfolgung am Start. Na ja, auf jeden Fall ist er zurückgeflogen. Er ist aus Gründen, die ich nicht so recht nachvollziehen kann, über London geflogen, über Heathrow. Also es ist ja auch nicht so, dass er nach England wollte, sondern er ist eigentlich nur im Transitbereich gewesen. Dort ist er dann von wem eigentlich? Vom Geheimdienst direkt, vom Border Control. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was jetzt die Entität war, die da offiziell aktiv geworden ist. Auf jeden Fall haben sie ihn festgehalten und das auf Basis eines Antiterror-Gesetzes, was es halt seit ein paar Jahren gibt, weil man muss ja was gegen den Terror tun. Und da kann man dann halt ohne Anklage, ohne Verdacht, ohne irgendwie nähere Angabe von Gründen, außer diffuse hier regiert der Terror. Und wir müssen uns da mal mit jemandem unterhalten. Knapp neun Stunden festgehalten. Neun Stunden ist in diesem Gesetz das festgeschriebene Maximum, was man darf. Und das wird normalerweise nicht ausgekostet. Nur hier ist es ausgekostet worden.
Also noch mal zu diesem Gesetz. Festnahme ohne richterliche Anordnung und ohne Recht auf juristischen Beistand ist in diesem Gesetz geregelt. Und du musst antworten. Du hast keine Aussage, Verweigerung ist Recht. Also wenn du nicht antwortest, kann es sein, dass du dich dadurch eben, also das ist automatisch Anlass zu, kann Anlass für Bestrafung sein. Das heißt, also so komplett...
Die komplette Aufhebung des Rechtsstaats.
Komplette Aufhebung des Rechtsstaats. Also alles weg, ja. Es liegt im Ermessen der Ermittlungsbehörden, ob sie dich festhalten oder nicht. Da haben wir unter normalen Umständen diese Richtergeschichte, also Polizei darf dich so und so lange festhalten. Dann muss ein Richter Untersuchungshaft anordnen wegen Fluchtgefahr oder du kannst wieder gehen. Dann juristischer Beistand, der dir ja eigentlich auch zu jedem Zeitpunkt deines Lebens zusteht, hast du da nicht. Und Aussageverweigerungsrecht hast du auch nicht.
Wobei der David Miranda wohl berichtet hat, dass sie ihm einen Anwalt angeboten hätten, er das aber ausgeschlagen hat, weil er nicht das Vertrauen hatte, dass die vorgeschlagene Person da in seinem Sinne gehandelt hätte. Wie auch das ihm angebotene Wasser. Also er hat auch diese neun Stunden lang nichts getrunken, weil er einfach nicht bereit war, Flüssigkeiten anzunehmen, was ich auch nachvollziehen kann. Gerade in der Situation, er hat dann wohl erst wieder was getrunken, als sie ihn dann mal an so einen Getränkeautomaten gelassen haben, wo so Dosen drin waren, wo ich zumindest so halbwegs sicher war, dass da jetzt Coca-Cola definiert, was da drin ist und nicht sonst irgendjemand anderes. Naja, aber sie haben ihn zumindest so weich gekocht, dass er auch Passwörter auf Anfrage rausgegeben hat für sein Telefon und andere Geräte.
Also sie haben ihn die ganze Zeit damit bedroht, dass er in einen Knast geht, dass jetzt hier alles kein Spaß ist, haben die Vices von ihm konfisziert und die Passwörter verlangt, also Rechner, zwei USB-Sticks, eine externe Festplatte und nicht weiter benannte weitere Geräte, darunter eine Spielkonsole, ein neues Telefon und eine Uhr. Der junge Mann ist 28 oder 29 Jahre alt und studiert irgendwie in Brasilien.
Ist der Glenn Greenwald eigentlich auch Brasilianer?
Ich weiß nicht, was für ein Pass der hat. Eventuell, also das weiß ich nicht. Aber das also so viel zu dem Umgang mit David Miranda. Okay, jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, eventuell da natürlich seinen Partner in dieser Sache unterstützt und sei es nur als engster Vertrauter. Also es ist jetzt, sag ich mal, die Vermutung ist naheliegend, dass wenn der Greenworld sich irgendjemandem anvertraut und mit irgendjemandem seine Lage bespricht, dann wird das wahrscheinlich sein Partner sein. Insofern da natürlich ein Anlass, den mal geheimdienstlich zu behandeln. Und natürlich kann man auch den Verdacht hegen, dass der David Miranda für ihn, was weiß ich, Botengänge macht, entsprechend diese Reaktion des Geheimdienstes, die aber natürlich im Vorgehen gegen einen Journalisten nach Anti-Terror-Gesetzen einfach nur absoluter Irrsinn ist. Also das ist eine unvorstellbare Sache, die da passiert ist. Ich wäre jetzt an seiner Stelle auch nicht unbedingt durch Großbritannien oder die USA geflogen.
Ja, das wundert mich so ein wenig, weil ausgerechnet nach Brasilien, also ich meine, wenn man dahin will, dann ist jetzt London auch nicht unbedingt die erste Wahl. Also da gibt es sehr viel, naja, es gibt halt vor allem natürlich Madrid, bietet sich da durchaus als Dreh- und Angelpunkt an, wobei man jetzt nicht sagen kann, dass Spanien und Frankreich so als, also auch über Paris gibt es glaube ich Verbindungen. Ja, wir haben ja gesehen, wie diese Länder sich so, genau, also das ist jetzt, war dann vielleicht auch egal, wenn gleich natürlich England und die spezifische Gesetzeslage dort ihnen natürlich auch bekannt gewesen. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie da was in Kauf genommen haben, ob es vielleicht auch von ihrer Seite her ein Test war oder vielleicht auch einfach schon, dass sie auch damit nicht gerechnet haben. Wobei, da werden wir ja gleich drauf kommen, wenn man sich so anschaut, was zu dem Zeitpunkt auch schon bekannt war, musste man eigentlich auch vom Schlimmsten ausgehen.
Genau, also diese Neuigkeit brach heraus. Es wurde dann gesagt, man sei jetzt ohne Sorge, was den Rechner angeht, weil da wären also alles Relevante auf den beschlagnahmten Rechner, der Rechner sei vernünftig verschlüsselt gewesen. Das hoffe ich, also die Vermutung würde ich auch hegen, dass wenn da irgendwas drauf war, dass er sich vorher informiert hat, wie man das so verschlüsselt, dass man sich eventuell überhaupt über irgendein Grenzübergang oder irgendeine Straße dieser Welt bewegen kann. Andererseits hätte ich da nicht so eine Gewissheit an, also ich meine okay, wenn sie es jetzt vernünftig gemacht haben und so, okay, aber...
Gewissheit, dass die gewählte Verschlüsselung auch wirklich sicher ist?
Na ja, die Verschlüsselungen sind sicher. Das geht hauptsächlich eher darum, wie dein Passwort aufbewahrt ist und ob nicht eventuell eh schon jemand deine Kiste mit einem Tojane ausgestattet hatte und daher das Passwort sowieso kennt für die Entschlüsselung dieser Dateien oder so. Also ich wäre da in dem Bereich der Geheimdienste dann schon ausreichend vorsichtig. Aber das ist jetzt auch zweitrangig, wie wir nachher sehen, was jetzt da die Dateien angeht oder nicht. Denn diese Geschichte wurde dann also veröffentlicht und es wurde angekündigt, dass man sich jetzt dagegen natürlich auch juristisch zu wehrsetzen wird. Juristisch zu wehrsetzen heißt, dass eigentlich nur irgendein Gericht im Nachhinein sagt, das war nicht rechtens, vielmehr kannst du da nicht mehr gewinnen. Vielleicht kriegst du deinen Computer zurück. In der Aufregung darüber schrieb dann der Alan Rusbridger, der Chefredakteur des Guardians, einen Blogpost, erstaunlich, also ein auffälliges Randnotiz, dass das eben nicht im Guardian selber geschrieben hat, sondern auf einem persönlichen Blog, wo er sagte, dass eigentlich seit der ersten Berichterstattung des Guardians über dieses Thema er immer wieder Anrufe bekommen hat und kontaktiert wurde und dass da immer von der Gefahr die Rede war. Also erst wurde ihm so, ja, okay, ihr hattet jetzt euren Spaß, jetzt wollen wir das Zeug zurück haben. Dann wurde ihm irgendwie gesagt, na ja, aber es gibt doch die Gefahr, dass vom Guardian die Materialien, die der Guardian hat, von dort an Terroristen und andere Geheimdienste liegen, und dann wurde er irgendwie erzählt, ja, du hast ja gar keine Vorstellung, was man heute machen kann. Mit so einer Laserkanone kann man die Vibrationen einer Fensterscheibe messen und dann sehen, was in dem Raum besprochen wurde und so. Du bist hier in gefährlichem Gewässer und deine OBSSEC reicht gar nicht aus, um mit solchen Materialien umzugehen. Gib die doch mal lieber uns. Willst du nicht hier dafür daran schuld sein, dass hier demnächst wieder Terroranstöge in London stattfinden oder so, wurde in allen Register eingezogen und das Ganze ging direkt zurück auf Jeremy Haywood, das ist quasi der Pofaller von, ne, das ist nicht der Pofaller, der Pofaller ist ja nur der Pofaller, aber die Position des Pofallers ist ja Kanzleramtsminister und das ist quasi der Geheimdienstbeauftragte der britischen Regierung. Geheimdienstbeauftragte, höchste Beamte und engster Mitarbeiter von dem Premierminister des Vereinigten Königreichs.
Genau.
Und dann wurde also irgendwie die ganze Zeit irgendwas erzählt und dann gipfelte das Ganze darin, dass gesagt wurde, ja, entweder ihr gebt uns das Zeug oder ihr zerstört es und der Russbreeder wies dann darauf hin und sagte, Jungs, euch ist schon klar, dass wir kopieren davon an anderen Orten in anderen Ländern haben und das, ob wir das jetzt zerstören oder nicht, spielt keine Rolle, also wird nichts ändern. Und dann mussten sie aber wohl im Keller der Redaktionsgebäude des Guardian unter Anleitung von GCHQ, Great Government Communications Headquarters, dem NSA Pendant des Vereinigten Königsreichs, dann da Festplatten und einen MacBook Air mit einer Flex oder mit einem Bohrer kaputt machen.
Nicht MacBook Air.
So sah das auf dem Foto, das kann aber ein MacBook gewesen sein. Das macht jetzt glaube ich den Unterschied.
Na es ist beides. Also da muss man den...
Na gut, bei dem MacBook Air kann man argumentieren, die SSD ist halt da reingelötet und wenn du die kaputt machen willst, muss halt, wie auch immer, also sie mussten, der Chefredakteur des Guardians musste im Keller des Redaktionsgebäudes unter Aufsicht und Anleitung von Geheimdienstmitarbeitern Festplatten zerstören, auf denen sich Material befand von Edward Snowden. Und da fällt ihr halt, und das auf direkte, das war jetzt nicht irgendein durchgeknallter Geheimdienstmitarbeiter, der meinte, er macht seinen Job mal richtig gut und will am Ende eine Beförderung haben, nein, das war auf direkte Anweisung der Regierung. Und da fällt einem, also da kann's...
Das ist einfach, ja, schlimmer geht's eigentlich fast gar nicht mehr.
Und jetzt sagt, jetzt tritt hier der Vize-Premier Nick Clack, sagt, ja, die Entscheidung habe ich mitgetragen, aber natürlich nur unter der Bedingung, dass der Guardian weiter veröffentlichen kann, weil die ja noch Kopien von dem Material haben.
Wozu dann die Geräte schreddern, fragt man sich auch.
Also man...
Das ist doch nur Intimidation, ich meine, in gewisser Hinsicht ist es natürlich auch ein Dokument der Hilflosigkeit.
Es ist ein Dokument der Hilflosigkeit. Also es ist natürlich eine unter keinen Umständen irgendwie zu tolerierende Aktion, was mich aber zu relativ ausführlichen Spekulationen motiviert hat. Der Guardian hat Kopien. Sie wissen, diese Handlung wird keinen nennenswerten Einfluss auf das Publikationsverhalten des Guardians haben.
Genau, gefesslicher Hinsicht schon, weil jetzt sind sie auf Kurs.
Okay, du kannst keine Schadensbegrenzung durch diese Aktion betreiben.
Ne, ja, nimmt man erstmal eine Eskalation in Kauf.
Genau.
So, genau, Punkt um eins. Wollten sie eine Eskalation provozieren? Wohl kaum. Die Frage ist, wenn ich weiß, die haben Kopien davon, was verspreche ich mir davon, dass ich ihre lokalen Daten zerstöre? Die Alternative wäre gewesen, dass der Guardian die aushändigt. Das hat der Guardian aber nicht gemacht. Die haben gesagt, bevor wir es euch geben, schneiden wir es in Stücke. Okay, in Ordnung, finde ich richtig an der Stelle. Jetzt ist die Frage, wollten die die eigentlich ganz gerne haben? Das ist eine interessante Information für uns jetzt.
Natürlich, würden sie es eigentlich gerne haben wollen.
Kennen sie die Inhalte schon?
Das ist die große Frage, weil wenn sie sich auf so was einlassen, ich meine, wenn sie sie noch nicht mal haben und nicht sehen, oder wenn sie überhaupt wissen, dass auf diesen Rechnern die drauf sind.
Auch eine Frage, das ist aber eine ganz andere Frage.
Ich denke, die haben wieder ein frisch installiertes OS X geschreddert.
Nee, das werden die wahrscheinlich, ist auch nochmal eine Frage, ob der Rusbridger so eisern war, da einfach irgendein altes MacBook von seiner Schwester oder seiner Tochter kleinzuschneiden und ihr neues zu schenken. Kann natürlich auch alles sein. Die Frage, die ich mir stelle, gehen wir mal davon aus, die Daten waren jetzt da drauf und GCHQ hat gezielt darauf hingearbeitet, dass die eben zerstört werden. In dem Wissen aber, dass die sich neue besorgen werden. So ging es denen vielleicht darum, dass sie erkennen wollten, okay, wo kriegt der Guardian die jetzt wieder her? Weil auf der Leitung von denen sitzen wir ja ohnehin. Die Telefone von denen hören wir ab, die Internetkommunikation von denen hören wir ab. Wollen wir gucken, wie die sich die wieder beschaffen? Wollen wir gucken, wer jetzt wo losfliegt? Oh, schau mal an, ein David Miranda ist auf einmal in Heathrow. Nein, nicht, dass der da irgendwo auf dem Klo eine Festplatte deponiert, damit die wieder in die Sonne...
Ja, aber die Daten liegen doch dann auch in diesem Gebäude, in ihrem Netzwerk auch mehrfach verschlüsselt drauf.
wie gesagt, okay, aber was sollte diese Aktion? Die werden sich doch irgendwas dabei gedacht haben. Und mir ist unklar, was sie sich dabei gedacht haben.
Bei mir ist es auch unklar. Es könnte natürlich auch unter Umständen sein, dass sie nicht gut nachgedacht haben. Dass sie irgendwie so eine symbolische Aktion, die gar nicht für die Öffentlichkeit bestimmt war, sondern nur für so eine governmentinterne Öffentlichkeit... So, guck mal, wir tun ja was, weil der Geheimdienst sich die ganze Zeit beschwert. Hier, ihr haut da nicht genug auf die Presse drauf. Und dann sagen die so, ja, Presse draufhauen schwierig und so. Ja, wir müssen die hier irgendwie mal einschüchtern. Macht mal was, geht da mal hin und macht mal nen Tanz.
So ist ja die Interpretation von Glenn Greenwald, der ja dann auch in einem Artikel oder in einem Kommentar schreibt, was das soll. Also eigentlich er sagt, sending a message. Also sie wollen einfach mit aller Kraft zeigen, dass hier der Spaß zu Ende ist. Und unter Umständen eben auch, das sehen wir ja, die Debatte wird ja geführt, seitdem diese ganzen Leaksachen so die größere Bewandtnis bekommen haben durch Wikileaks und deren Veröffentlichungen. Dass man, dass quasi die Regierungen sagen, Pressefreiheit ist nicht, also die Pressefreiheit hat Grenzen. Und zwar nicht im Sinne von wir begrenzen sie, sondern auch die Pressefreiheit darf nicht missbraucht werden. Das ist ja quasi deren Argumentation ist ja. Hier findet im Prinzip Spionage und Geheimnisverrat statt. Und das ist nicht durch die Pressefreiheit geschützt. So ist ja deren Position.
Obwohl es ja nicht genau andersrum ist.
Das ist ja die Argumentation, die sie vortragen. Und sagen, was ihr hier macht ist nicht mehr Berichterstattung, sondern aktives Beschädigen des Landes.
Die haben Glück, dass Steve Jobs tot ist. Der würde denen einen Lauf geben, MacBook Air schreddern.
Dem doch egal, solange die ein neues kaufen.
Der macht die zur Schnecke.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Steve Jobs...
Steve Jobs und David Cameron in einem Fahrstuhl. Ich glaube nicht, dass David Cameron das überleben würde.
Na ja, also mir fallen andere Leute ein, denen ich mehr macht oder mehr... Macht?
Ich rede nicht von Macht.
Ich rede von jemandem, der ordentlich zur Schnecke zu machen.
Ganz geschreddert haben sie es nicht. Sie haben offensichtlich auf die Stellen gezeigt, wo der Bohrer reingehauen werden musste. Aber wie gesagt, diese Aktion ist absoluter Unsinn.
Glück zum Glück verhindert sie nicht. Ich habe sogar ein Statement vom Menschenrechtsbeauftragten der FDP gelesen, der das irgendwie nicht okay fand.
Ja, und jetzt? Finden wir nicht okay.
Wahlkampf muss man auch mal was nicht okay finden. Dann geht er wieder zurück auf seine Hinterbank und sitzt die letzten paar Wochen noch erfolgreich ab.
Menschenrechtsbeauftragter der FDP, ich bitte dich, so ein Quatsch. Das ist wie der Datenschutzbeauftragte bei Facebook oder was? Also man kann einfach nur sagen, das ist jetzt der offene Krieg. Es gibt keine Grenzen mehr, es gibt keinen Schutz mehr. Das ist jetzt hier der offene Kampf und wir können uns hier unsere ganze Vorstellung von Rechtsstaat und so echt mal langsam an den Hut stecken. Und dadurch, dass solche Dinge passieren und dass das wird ohne Konsequenzen bleiben. Allenfalls wird es jetzt irgendwie mal eine Feststellung geben, dass vielleicht in vier Jahren irgendein Gericht urteilt und sagt hör mal, den Miranda, den hättet ihr damals nicht festhalten dürfen oder nicht festhalten sollen, aber ihr habt gegen kein Gesetz verstoßen, weil das Gesetz sagt ja ihr dürft das. So wird diese Nummer sein. Und ich mein, ein Premierminister, der damit durchkommt, die Presse anzugreifen. Also wenn sowas in Russland passieren würde, dann müsste der Schröder durch jede Zeitung mit seiner Aussage, dass das ein lupenreiner Demokrat wäre, der Schröder zu Kreuz kriechen dürfen. Wenn sowas in Russland passieren würde, wäre der Wahnsinn wäre los. Und das ist ja das, was wir ja auch die ganze Zeit in diesem Podcast betonen, ist, dass es hier um Interessen geht. Und nicht um irgendwelche Rechtsstaatssachen oder so. Und wir sehen, dass wir uns das alles von der Backe putzen können. Unsere komplette Rechtsstaatsnummer, sei das diese Überwachung, sei dass wir jetzt mit der Enthüllung über diese Überwachung umgegangen werden.
Das ist jetzt die britische. Also wir reden ja jetzt hier im Wesentlichen über UK. Man kann jetzt über die politische Reaktion in Deutschland auch nochmal debattieren. Die ist sicherlich halbherzig. Die sind natürlich auch alle gerade in Schockstarre. Aber das geht auch alles gar nicht. Aber wir wissen auch, dieselbe Aktion jetzt beim Spiegel, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das genauso unter den Tisch gekehrt werden würde, wie... also da wäre dann hier schon langsam auch mal der eine oder andere Lieferwagen eher so auf 90 Grad.
Ein wichtiger Punkt, den du ansprichst, denn die anderen britischen großen Verlagshäuser und Publikationen haben diese Geschichte jetzt nicht so besonders groß gebracht.
Nee, das ist halt in Britannien...
Die haben auch keine Pressefreiheit.
Das Land ist auch durch. Ich meine, das ist wirklich schon lange durch. Das ist jetzt irgendwie keine neue Entwicklung. Diese ganze Überwachungs-Startnummer und so weiter, das fahren die da jetzt seit 10, 20 Jahren. Da ist einfach mal Orwell, hätte sich schon ein bisschen mehr Mühe geben können. Die haben das einfach durchimplementiert da. Und die finden das irgendwie auch total normal. Und die sind auch alle so hirngewaschen, dass sie das einfach zur Kenntnis nehmen. Das ist jetzt alles sicherer. Das ist irgendwie ein Land ohne Rückgrat und eine Gesellschaft, die nicht dafür kämpft, sich ihre Rechte zu erhalten oder nicht wirklich sieht, wohin die Reise geht. So sehe ich das. Das ist eine sehr persönliche Meinung, aber die sind einfach durch. Ich finde es ehrlich gesagt, um gleich nochmal ein paar andere unpopuläre Thesen hinterherzuschmeißen, vielleicht sind sie gar nicht mehr so unpopulär usw. Wahrscheinlich wären wir dann auch irgendwie in der EU auch mal besser dran ohne die.
Ok, jetzt kriegst du in den Kommentaren wieder was um die Ohren. Was mich interessieren oder was ich da... Also ohne das jetzt wirklich so auf diese Bevölkerung zu betonen, dass das jetzt diese Bevölkerung ist, würde ich da eigentlich gerne mal so zeigen, was so die normative Kraft des Faktischen ist. In dem Moment, wo du so was einmal machst, mit durch diese kleinen Schritte, du knallst erstmal das ganze Land mit Kameras voll. Und dann regen sich da noch ein paar Jahre vielleicht Leute drüber auf. Und dann meldest du irgendwann, ja hier weniger Fahrräder geklaut oder was auch immer. In dem Moment, wo du einmal so ein Überwachungssystem drin hast, kriegst du hinten nie wieder raus. Und die Bevölkerung hat sich daran gewöhnt. Und du kannst dann wieder einen Schritt weitergehen. Weil das, was du machst, ist immer wieder automatisch normal. In dem Moment, wo das Gesetz ist, wo du so eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung hast oder so, in dem Moment ist das normal. Das ist die Baseline für alle. Das dauert ein Jahr, dann haben sich da alle dran gewöhnt. Und dann kannst du so eine Aktion eben bringen. Dann hältst du halt mal jemanden am Flughafen fest. Auch das jetzt. Selbst ich sag ja gerade so aus taktischen Erwägungen, kann ich das verstehen, dass sie das gemacht haben. So ganz klar, sie wollten den einschüchtern. Sie konnten, eventuell hatten sie eine Chance darauf, irgendwas aus dem rauszukriegen. Ich meine, was meinst du, was die jetzt auf der Suche sind, dass der Green World irgendwas macht, wofür man den ernsthaft mal einknasten kann. Dass man den endlich als Staatsfeind abstempeln kann. Die werden irgendwann, das kommt ja jetzt alles noch. Das hat ja schon so ein bisschen angefangen, dieses Personalisiert. Und sei es nur, dass jetzt alle wissen, dass der homosexueller ist, mit, weiß nicht, zehn Jahren jüngeren Brasilianer.
Schöne Botschaft nach Ausland.
So, damit machst du auch Sympathien kaputt. In bestimmten Teilen der Welt und der Gesellschaften in den jeweiligen betroffenen Ländern. Und das ist, da wird halt jetzt, der Kampf ist halt, es gibt, der Kampf ist jetzt ohne Regeln. Das ist das, was ich meine. Es ist jetzt einfach offen und sie kommen damit durch. Also, wie du gerade schon sagtest, ich hoffe, ich hoffe, dass wenn in Deutschland ein Angriff auf die Pressefreiheit stattfindet, noch nicht mal in dem Ausmaß, viel kleinerer Angriff, dass hier sofort die Straße brennt. Aber ich bin mir da nicht mehr so sicher. Und das ist genau das, was ich meine so, dass die Gesellschaft, veränderst du, das wird alles wieder Baseline. Die Leute merken, ach, okay, ich hab meinen Job trotzdem nicht verloren. Mein Leben hat sich nicht so sehr verändert. Und das ist jetzt wieder normal. Und jetzt ist da wieder ein kleiner Ausfall. Aber die haben ja schon gesagt, der Vize-Premier sagt ja, dass das alles nur unter der Bedingung, dass der Guardian weiter veröffentlichen kann, gemacht wurde. Das heißt, die haben doch schon die Pressefreiheit gewahrt. Das heißt, das ist jetzt alles noch okay. Das ist jetzt so quasi das, was die Grenzen werden immer mehr ausgehöhlt. Die Grenzen dessen, wo man denkt, oh, das wird schockierend krass so. Aber okay, das ist jetzt mal passiert, das war jetzt eine Ausnahme.
Ja, was mich einfach besonders beunruhigt, um nochmal meine potenziell umstrittene Äußerung nochmal irgendwie anders zu beleuchten, dass es sich hierbei einfach um ein Land der EU handelt, was im Prinzip unsere generellen Überzeugungen von Demokratie und freiheitlicher Gesellschaft etc. teilt. Ich meine, da ist nicht nur Britannien ein Problem, da ist natürlich auch genauso Ungarn ein Problem auf einem anderen Level. Also gerade wenn wir über Pressefreiheit reden und so, wissen wir ja, Ungarn haben wir hier jemals schon mal über Ungarn gesprochen, sollten wir vielleicht irgendwann mal tun. Auf jeden Fall, das halte ich einfach auch für ein echtes Problem. Und ich halte das auch für etwas, was man jetzt mal thematisieren muss. Ja, ich sage jetzt nicht gleich sofort hier irgendwie, die Insel um 1000 Kilometer verschieben, Grenzsäone aufziehen, die existieren eh. Also faktisch ist das Land nicht integriert. Nur die Debatte muss man einfach führen. Was wollen wir für eine Gesellschaft haben? Und ist so ein Verhalten Teil unserer Gesellschaft? Und es ist ja unsere Gesellschaft. An der Stelle gebe ich dir ja wieder recht, wenn du sagst, so unser Rechtsstaat ist jetzt in Gefahr, insofern als das ja Britannien sehr wohl Teil unserer Rechtsordnung ist, weil wir ja einen europäischen Verbund teilen. Das ist jetzt nicht Ausland im eigentlichen Sinne.
Das ist aber auch genau die Gefahr dieses Argumentes, wenn man irgendwie sagt, stell dir mal vor im anderen Land, sei froh, dass du nicht in dem Land bist. Und jetzt können wir halt schon nach Großbritannien zeigen. Also wie gesagt, wir haben jetzt gerade über Homosexualität gesprochen, dann kam so eine Anmerkung, sei froh, dass du nicht in Russland bist, viel schlimmer.
Bisher war es immer so China, USA, immer die fernen Länder und so.
In China wird es dir ganz anders gehen. Das ist aber auch schon ein Argument, mit dem man sehr vorsichtig sein muss, weil das zeigt, dass man quasi schon akzeptiert, dass es in China normal ist. Und jetzt sind wir so weit, dass wir nach Großbritannien zeigen, paar hundert Meter über den Teich und sagen, hier, sei froh, dass dein Verlagshaus nicht in Großbritannien ist. Sei froh, dass hier, du ärgerst dich über eine Überwachungskamera, sei froh, dass du nicht in London wohnst.
Interessant ist, es gibt ja einen Begriff Anti-Amerikanismus, aber ich wüsste überhaupt nicht, wie das Wort mit Britannien gebildet werden müsste.
Na, ich weiß nicht, Solidaritätsmangel gegenüber der Krone oder, weiß nicht. Ich weiß es, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich wollte nur mal so einen Ausblick machen, was man als nächstes so vorgeworfen bekommt, aber so sonderlich populär ist es halt nicht.
Man merkt, glaube ich, wie wir hier eigentlich mehr oder weniger fassungslos stehen. Es gab dann noch die Meldung, dass, also ich kenne mich jetzt mit den Gesetzen in den UK nicht besonders aus, muss ich zugeben. Ich habe aber gelesen, dass es jetzt kein unmittelbares Gesetz gäbe, wonach das jetzt irgendwie eine problematische Aktion wäre.
Das kein Problem ist, dass es einfach in Großbritannien überhaupt keine Verfassung gibt.
Genau, es gibt keine Verfassung und damit gibt es auch keine großartige Pressefreiheit. Das Einzige, was jetzt anstünde, wäre also die EU-Grundrecht-Charta. Sagt man Charta oder Karta? Ich weiß nicht. Grundrechte Karta, Charter, Charterflug, Grundrechte Karta. Artikel 11 Recht auf freie Meinungsäußerung. Aber Brüssel sieht da jetzt auch keinen großartigen Grund einzugreifen, weil die Mitgliedstaaten das alles irgendwie so individuell befolgen können. Also die EU-Grundrechte, Charter ist jetzt Karta. Charter ist da jetzt nicht von berührt, sagt ein Sprecher der EU-Kommission. Das heißt, die EU sagt jetzt, toleriert das jetzt. Also so viel zum Thema, was die EU macht oder auch immer. Es ist, ich glaube, es ist einfach schockierend. Man kann da nichts mehr zu sagen. Es werden einfach jetzt täglich Grundfeste von dem erschüttert, was mir als Jugendlicher an Überzeugungen eingeimpft wurde oder als Heranwachsender, wo mir erklärt wurde, warum die Demokratie und der Rechtsstaat etwas sind, was ich lieben, ehren und schützen soll. Und das wird jetzt hier am laufenden Band in einem Maße verletzt, das ich mir nicht hätte vorstellen können.
Ja, mal gucken, wie sich das noch steigert. Heißt zumindest Karta.
Karta? Entschuldigung.
Wir haben jetzt auch gerade 100 Probe. Welche Ausnahmen es da jetzt noch gibt? Bei deinem nächsten Karta-Flug musst du das bedenken.
Ich flieg bald wieder Karta. So, in den USA hat sich auch ein bisschen was getan.
Das ist ja auch mal eine Neuigkeit.
Und zwar ging es ja dann wieder um diese Zahlen, Internetverkehr, die sie überwacht haben.
Nur 1,6 Prozent.
Ja, wir hatten ja da schon irgendwie gesprochen. Da haben sie ja sogar in ihrer eigenen Veröffentlichung dann noch einen Komma-Fehler gemacht. Den hab ich hier glaube ich auch letztes Mal mit vorgelesen. Also dieses 1,6 Mal, die so und so, die sie hatten. Da waren sie ja dann bei 0,00004. Da wären aber 0,004 gewesen oder so. Ist jetzt auch egal. Und jetzt sagte dann das Wall Street Journal, haben sich dann mit Snowden Dokumente und sich mit aktiven und ehemaligen NSA-Mitarbeitern unterhalten. Und da haben dann nochmal so die Schätzung in den Raum gesetzt, dass sie so 75% des US-Internetverkehrs in ihre Schläuche bekommen. Und dann aber weiterhin ja irgendwie darauf achten, dass eine Partei außerhalb der USA ist. Und wohl in ihrem Land so mehr als ein Dutzend Sonden haben. Also ich hab's jetzt mal Sonden genannt. Also Tabs, also Dinge, wo sie halt aktiv mitschnorcheln. Und das wird ja dann am Ende irgendwo zentral zusammengeführt. Aber diese, quasi die Abhöreinheiten selber können sie quasi noch mal so ein bisschen feintunen. Das heißt so, die machen so einen zweistufigen Prozess. Irgendwie bei den Telcos wird was rausgeroutet. Und das wird dann da nochmal analysiert. Und dann kommt's irgendwann so in mehreren Stufen, landet's dann einfach in der zentralen Datenbank. In dem Artikel des Wall Street Journal wird gesagt, das hab ich, also diesen Satz hab ich mehrfach gelesen, dass die Telcos entscheiden, was vermutlich relevant für Foreign Intelligence ist. Das kann ich mir, obwohl, wie gesagt, ich hab den Satz mehrfach gelesen, aber steht da so. Ich kann mir das aber nicht vorstellen, dass diese Entscheidung oder überhaupt einen Einfluss auf diese Umsetzung tatsächlich den Telcos überlassen. Aber der Satz steht da so, deswegen geb ich den so wieder. Das wär so die erste Ebene.
Na wenn sie das rausfiltern oder rausrouten, dann ist ja die Frage, wer entscheidet, auf welcher technischen Basis das geht. Das kann ja sein, dass es sehr wohl bei ihnen läuft, aber dann die Konfiguration frei Haus geliefert wird.
Aber genau, diese Kriterien kann ich ja nicht dem Telco überlassen.
Ne, ne, das kommt dann wahrscheinlich einfach per Amazon Prime irgendwie kostenlosen Päckchen dazu.
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Also ich würde nach wie vor davon ausgehen, dass sie da Blackboxen hinstellen, auf denen eventuell bestimmte Filter sind, dass aber die Modifikation der Filterregeln nicht in der Hand der Telcos ist und auch nicht die Kenntnis darüber. Aber okay, es stand da jetzt so, deswegen geb ich das so wieder. Und dann kopiert die NSA erstmal alles und wählt dann eben nochmal aus, was relevant ist. Und das ist so dieser Unterschied zwischen drei Tage alles und auf Ewigkeit das Relevante gespeichert. Und dann wurde also mal so ein Beispiel benannt, wo sie 2002 zusammen mit dem Provider Qwest die Inhalte aller E-Mails und aller Textkommunikation in der im Bereich um Salt Lake City gemonitert haben für etwas unter sechs Monaten, weil da waren ja dann die Winterspiele. Und da ist ja auch immer Terror. Das waren dann so Beispiele, die in dem Wall Street Journal Artikel dann mal so...
Da magst du dich gar nicht vorstellen, was in Britannien letztes Jahr oder vorletztes Jahr zur Olympia gelaufen sein muss.
Da haben sie ja wirklich alles rausgefallen. Das Schönste fand ich ja, da hatten sie ja dann Polizisten mit so Hand-IMSY-Catchern, mit so Richtantennen-IMSY-Catchern und die fuhren glaub ich sogar auf Rollschuhen rum. Ich hab das Bild jetzt nicht mehr gefunden, aber ich erinnere mich daran, das war so eine kleine Handpistole mit so einer Richtantenne dran.
Auf Rollschuhen?
Oder auf Inlineskater oder so was. Oder ein Fahrrad, ich weiß es nicht. Ich hab das Bild nicht mehr gefunden, ich hab es zur Sendungsvorbereitung rausgesucht. Imseacatcher, also Geräte zum Ausspielen von... Zum Vorspielen eines Telefonnetzes. Oder auch erst mal nur zur Feinortung von Personen. Aber genau, Imseacatcher, ein Gerät, was eine Base Station, also ein Funkzellenmast simuliert.
Was so tut, als wäre es das Netz und dein Telefon bucht sich da ein. Und dann weiß der Imseacatcher wo du bist. Beim Inlines geht er und stellt dich irgendwie durch oder fängt es komplett ab.
Völlig irrsinnig. Und heute kam dann raus, zwischen 2008 und 2011 hatten wir da so ein kleines technisches Problem mit unseren Filtern, die ja erkennen sollen, ob das mindestens eine Partei im Ausland ist. Weil wir ja inländische Kommunikation nicht abhören. Und da sind also mehr als 50.000 E-Mails pro Jahr, die also in einer amerikanischen Kommunikation waren auch irgendwie in diesen Filtern gelandet. Aber das war so ein kleines technisches Problem, eine kleine Fehlkonfiguration. Aber das ist das einzige, wo man jetzt da hoffen kann, dass innerhalb der USA da nochmal irgendwie ein bisschen Schmackes in die Angelegenheit kommt. Und, naja, jetzt haben sie halt... Jetzt hat sich der Director of National Intelligence im Rahmen von der durch Obama angekündigten Transparenz... Also ich hab jetzt wirklich fünfmal drauf geguckt. Der hat jetzt einen Tumblr-Blog. Der hat jetzt einen Tumblr, wo sie Official Statements und Declassified Information raushauen. Und wo es dann immer unter die Section 702 des Foreign Intelligence Surveillance Acts geht, wo sie dann irgendwie Dokumente deklassifizieren und veröffentlichen. Das ist, wir erinnern uns, das sind dann die Informationen, die sich der Friedrich dann angucken kann. Weil der muss sie erwarten, bis sie... Im Prinzip, das ist das, was der Friedrich... Da gibt es jetzt eine Transparenz Offensive und so. Ein Tumblr-Blog.
Ja, das ist so eine Art Geheimdienst-YouTube. Kann ja jeder jetzt irgendwas hochladen und so.
Die Links, die Dateien...
Kann man das auch liken?
Retumblern oder so kann es das wahrscheinlich.
Das ist auch volle Tumblr...
Naja, jetzt hab ich mein Dokument angeklickt, ja. Und wie sieht das Dokument aus? Da ist halt alles geschwärzt.
Super, mal gucken. Vielleicht ist da so ein PDF vor, wo dahinter die eigentliche Information steht.
Auf Seite 6 kann man dann mal einen Absatz lesen. Das ist ja total skurril. Geil. 13 Seiten, alles schwarz. Und auf Seite 6 gibt es einen halben Absatz, den man lesen kann. Super, das müssen wir auch nochmal verlinken. Okay, also die Transparenz-Offensive ist da im vollen Gange. Also man weiß gar nicht mehr, was man dazu noch sagen soll.
Das ist wirklich ein nebeles Kerzenweihdruck.
Also ich bin fast, scroll mal runter. Seite 2 alles schwarz, Seite 3 alles schwarz, Seite 4 alles schwarz, Seite 5 alles schwarz. Seite 6, jetzt pass auf, da gibt es nämlich einen kleinen, was ist das jetzt? So eine Viertelseite.
Hier gibt jemand eine Opinion ab.
Oh, Seite 7 ist auch noch mal. Ganz wenig nur geschwärzt auf Seite 7.
Diese schönen Tweets-Zitate mit irgendwie das Schlimme an Zensur ist, das kann man hier sehr schön nachlesen.
Das drucke ich aus. Wenn meine Druckerpatrone das noch mitmacht.
Ja, wenn man sich das mal 14 Seiten von denen wirklich das meiste schwarz ist. Ich guck mir das hier noch mal kurz im Overview an. Das ist herrlich ganz putzig hier, wenn man sich einfach mal nur alle Seiten anschaut. Also was soll man dazu noch sagen?
Also ja, wir haben das mal als Beispiel verlinkt. Kann man sich mal anschauen. Hübsch. Ich weiß halt nicht, wie lange man über diesen ganzen...
Kram noch lachen kann?
Kram noch lachen kann.
Das ist jetzt eh alles schon... Wie sagt man so schön, das Pfeifen im Walde hier. Wir haben keine Angst.
So.
Unglaublich.
Gibt aber noch eine Neuigkeit aus den USA. Wirklich? Wir erinnern uns an Bradley Manning, der maximal irgendwie in Richtung 90 Jahre Knast geblickt hat. Dann forderte die Staatsanwaltschaft 60 Jahre. Wir erinnern uns, dass er vor Gerichtern noch so eine zweiminütige Entschuldigung rausgepresst hat, nachdem man ihn verurteilt hatte. Es ging jetzt nur noch darum, wie lange man ihn jetzt wegschließen wird. Und es gab einen Urteil. Das Urteil lautet auf 35 Jahre Haft. Bei guter Führung könnte er das jetzt irgendwie so...
Ich glaube, die Verteidigung hat 20 Jahre gefordert.
Ich weiß nicht, was die Verteidigung gefordert hat.
Ich habe zumindest eine Interpretation gelesen, wo es so hieß, alles unter 20 wäre ein Gewinn der Verteidigung gewesen. Und 35 ist dann doch noch eher viel. Auch wenn da 90 gefordert wurde. Aber ich meine, das ist ja eher alles absurd.
Nee, gefordert wurden 60 von der Staatsanwaltschaft.
Entschuldigung. Maximum waren 90 gefordert, waren 60.
Wir reden von Jahren. Also 35 Jahre. Ein paar Jahre mehr, als Bradley Manning jetzt alt ist. So, und jetzt ist das so, weil es liest man irgendwie so, bei guter Führung könnte das heißen, dass er nach 18 Jahren raus kann. Eine Bewährung ist schon nach einem Drittel möglich. Das Drittel ist also dann bei knapp 11,5 Jahren oder 11,9 Jahren. Etwas über drei Jahre ist er ja aber schon im Knast. Das wird angerechnet. Sodass WikiLeaks jetzt sagt, ey großartig, in 8,5 Jahren hat er die erste Möglichkeit, da rauszukommen. Die ganze Angelegenheit geht aufgrund des hohen Strafmaßes automatisch an das Berufungsgericht Court of Appeals nach einem Jahr. Kann aber früher dorthin gebracht werden, wenn Bradley Manning und sein Anwalt sich dazu entscheiden, das zu machen. Der Anwalt von Bradley Manning sagt, er hat in seiner Laufbahn Mörder und Vergewaltiger verteidigt. Und niemand hat so ein hohes Strafmaß erhalten wie Bradley Manning. Er hat auch angekündigt, dass Bradley Manning Barack Obama um Begnadigung bitten wird. Das finde ich mal geil. Auf die Antwort bin ich gespannt.
Reicht es sich da einfach nur Nein zu sagen?
Nein, da sagen sie in der Regel einfach Nein. Das wird, glaube ich, einmal im Jahr gemacht. Ich kenne diesen ganzen Begnadigungsprozess auch nur aus The West Wing. Das muss man mal gucken. Das Weiße Haus hat dieses Begnadigungsgesuch entgegengenommen und hat gesagt, das legen wir jetzt zu den anderen und werden das genauso behandeln wie die anderen, was ja auch okay ist. Was man da eigentlich nur noch als Randnotiz benennen darf, ist eines der Manning Leaks war ja das Video Collateral Murder, wo eine Bande Soldaten in einem Kampfhubschrauber Zivilisten tötet und in einem zweiten Angriff die Zivilisten, die den verletzten Zivilisten helfen wollen, vor den Augen der Kinder, die nur verletzt werden, weil sie in Autos sitzen. Genau, Journalisten, die beiden Reuters Journalisten, deren Kameras dann laut Untersuchungskommission nicht von Gewehren zu unterscheiden waren. Und die Untersuchungskommission, die ja dann als Ergebnis dieser Untersuchung dieses Vorfalls sagte, ja, das wäre also schon besser, wenn Journalisten irgendwie Westen tragen würden oder Erkennungsmerkmale und das Militär einfach besser über ihre Aufenthaltsorte unterrichten würden. Also, mit anderen Worten, die Journalisten sollten dem Militär melden, wo sie ihren Journalismus betreiben, damit das Militär sie nicht versehentlich abmetzelt. Das ist das Ergebnis gewesen. Wohl, aber nicht auch nur die Aufnahme eines Verfahrens gegen die Menschen, die diesen Hubschrauber gesteuert haben und dieses 30-Millimeter-Maschinengewehr. An dem Helikopter ist ein Maschinengewehr, das schießt 30-Millimeter-Projektile. Also 3 Zentimeter Durchmesser hat das Projektil. So ein normaler Handfeuerwaffe hat 9 Millimeter. Und ein Maschinengewehr wird dann zwischen 8 und 12 Millimeter.
Das sind schon Kanonen eigentlich.
Das sind Kanonen, wahrscheinlich sogar noch kleinere Projektile. Also das ist halt so eine AK-47, weiß nicht. Ich glaube, Gewehre haben dann noch mal dünnere Projektile. Aber wie auch immer, ich kenne jetzt keinen Ballistiker.
Und auch kein Fass.
Hat so eine AK-47?
Typischen Kaliber von Maschinengewehren.
Das ist auch schon groß.
2020 bezeichnet man das als Maschinenkanonen.
Also mit einer Maschinenkanone hat dieser Hubschrauber auf diese Journalisten geschossen. Und das ja dann auch noch vertuscht, weil Reuters sicher dann dafür interessiert hat, wo ihre Journalisten, unter welchen Umständen, die ihnen da zerfetzt wurden.
Ja, aber die Leute, die sagen, hier ist scheiße gelaufen, die werden einfach verurteilt und das ist halt alles hart.
Die Leute, die das an die Öffentlichkeit bringen, kriegen einen Gerichtsurteil über 35 Jahre. Und die Soldaten, die da einfach nach Lust und Laune, wie in so einem Ballerspiel, Journalisten und Zivilisten töten, die kriegen noch nicht mal ein Verfahren.
Und ehrenhafte Entlassungen, wie Manning ja auch noch oben drauf bekommen hat, wobei das glaube ich noch bei allen das geringste Problem ist. Da kann er sich eher freuen. Ich bin mal gespannt, wie sich der Friedensnobelpreisträger Barack Obama da dann gegenüber der Begnadigung so anstellt. Gibt es da eigentlich schon irgendwelche Bewegungen, die die Rücknahme dieses Nobelpreises fordern? Oder ist das einfach sowieso alles total egal?
Da ist mir nichts bekannt. Interessant ist es auf jeden Fall. Peter Pixar schlug ja vor, man müsste jetzt einfach mal dafür sorgen, dass der Bradley Manning den auch kriegt. Und dann mal schauen, was passiert. Wahrscheinlich würde Obama unter Protest dann seinen zurückgeben.
Es gibt ja ein Mitglied der vorschlagsberechtigten Gruppe, da habe ich jetzt leider keinen Link parat, aber das habe ich gelesen, der meines Wissens Snowden schon quasi vorgeschlagen hat, für den Friedensnobelpreis. In seiner Argumentation meinte er, das wäre auch einfach erforderlich, um sich diese große Blamage, die sich das Nobelpreiskomitee mit der Verleihung an Obama gegeben hat, was der größte Fehler gewesen wäre, wenn sie da begangen hätten, das irgendwie auszuwetzen. Ich glaube nicht, dass es dazu kommen wird. Das wäre wirklich eine Überraschung, ja. Aber das ist schon, sagen wir mal, zumindest in Teilen, glaube ich, ist da schon Scham vorhanden. Inwiefern diese Institute...
Die haben diesen Preis absolut erhöhnt.
Ja, der ist jetzt wirklich nichts mehr wert. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich.
Also ich meine, es war ja schon, also da waren ja schon einige verrückte Träger dabei. Also ich meine, Yasir Arafat, der mit der Knarre im Halfter irgendwie im UN-Gebäude spricht, war ja auch... Friedenssobelpe heißt es, Hega.
Aber ich meine, da gab es zumindest konkrete Bemühungen, die da tatsächlich erfolgt sind. Da gab es wirklich abgeschlossene Friedensverträge, dass die jetzt nicht in verbündete Landschaften geführt hat. Das ist nochmal ein anderes Problem. Aber bisher gab es halt auch wirklich irgendwie Fleisch bei der ganzen Sache. Und bei Barack Obama hat man sich ja sozusagen im Wesentlichen nur für die Änderung des Umgangs mit der Welt. Das war ja so im Wesentlichen die Argumentation. Weil ich meine, vorzuweisen hatte er ja nichts. Das war sozusagen nur, dass er begonnen hat, schöne Reden zu halten und einen anderen diplomatischen Usus heranzuziehen. Zumindest etwas, was sie meinten, was irgendwie anders sei. Dass sich da jetzt so sehr viel nicht verändert hat. Außer dass die Lust der Amerikaner, in den offenen Krieg zu ziehen, ein bisschen zu abgenommen hat. Aber ich denke, das ist halt auch eher den Ergebnissen der letzten Kriege geschuldet. Und nicht unbedingt, dass es sich jetzt hier bei einer Nation handelt, die jetzt auf einmal friedliebend und irgendwie pazifistisch der Welt gegenüber tritt.
Ja, also nochmal ganz kurz bevor ich mir den Unmut jener, die den Israel-Palästina-Konflikt mit Emotionen betrachten, einhandle, einhandel, einfange, Yasser Arafat zusammen mit Shimon Peres und noch jemandem, Yitzhak Rabin, der Generalstabschef der israelischen Streitkräfte. Die drei haben zusammen 1994 den Friedensnobelpreis bekommen für ihre Friedensverhandlungen, die ja auch echt irgendwie einen vernünftigen Eindruck gemacht haben. Ich wollte damit auch nur sagen, dass ein bewaffneter Mann, der diese Pistole als Zeichen des Kampfes nicht ablegt, das ist natürlich schon auch ein Statement, dem Friedensnobelpreis zu geben. Oder den damit rumrennen zu lassen.
Ich meine, man kann jetzt über die Bedeutung dieses Nobelpreises ohnehin diskutieren.
Der ist komplett im Arsch. Vielleicht, wenn man den Obama gegeben hat, ist der im Arsch.
Ja gut, aber der hat auch vorher nicht unbedingt jetzt besonders viel bewirkt. Zumindest nicht global. Also da kann man darüber diskutieren. Dass der angesehen ist und dass es immer ein Aufreger ist. Wenn jemand verliehen wird, klar, das ist halt einfach so.
Der Friedensnobelpreis ist so ein Ding, was einfach bestimmt, der Friedensnobelpreis gibt dir die moralische Anerkennung des Gutes. Du bist der Gute. Du bist auf der richtigen Seite.
Zumindest mal für einen bestimmten Moment.
Du bist genau so. Und als Friedensnobelpreisträger kriegst du quasi eine hohe ethisch-moralische Autorität, die dich für dein Handeln mit diesem Preis auszeichnet.
Barack Obama hat es wahrscheinlich auch nicht unbedingt als Person bekommen, sondern es war so, okay, liebe USA, wir haben euch auch echt viel lieber, wenn ihr irgendwie nicht total durchdreht, weil irgendwie diese Bush-Nummer, das ging jetzt mal gar nicht. Das war eigentlich im Wesentlichen die Aussage. So ein bisschen in der Erwartung, dass man jetzt wirklich in eine andere Richtung fährt, nur das zeichnet sich halt nicht ab. Also diese andere Richtung kann ich jetzt so nur eingeschränkt sehen.
Man hätte sich vielleicht auch erhofft, dass jemand, der diesen Preis hat, den dann auch versucht, in Würde zu tragen. Und das hat Barack Obama ganz offensichtlich nicht getan.
Bevor wir uns hier noch weiter in internationale Friedensdiskussionskonflikte und sonstige...
Ich glaube, der Friedensverbeerprägung ist irgendwie so wie so ein Bundesverdienstkreuz. Willst du da auch einfach nicht haben. Also willst du erstens nicht die Anerkennung der Bundesregierung haben und du willst auch nicht auf einer Liste mit den ganzen Arschgeigen stehen, die das inzwischen tragen.
Raul Krauthausen hat eins.
Also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich würde es nicht annehmen. Aber das ist eine andere Geschichte. Das ist ja eine Herausforderung, vor der Menschen stehen, denen solche Anerkennung gegeben werden. Es gibt viele gute Menschen, die den Bundesverdienstkreuz bekommen haben. Aber du musst halt irgendwann überlegen, willst du von dieser Institution, willst du ein Würdenträger für diese Institution sein, Bundesrepublik Deutschland, die das vergibt, und willst du auf einer Liste mit den anderen Leuten stehen, die das so haben?
Man wird ja jetzt nicht unbedingt verglichen mit all den Bösen. Man könnte ja auch genauso anders argumentieren, wenn ich jetzt ein total toller Typ bin und ich kriege jetzt ein Bundesverdienstkreuz und dann erweitere ich sozusagen die Liste der Leute, die auch wirklich einen Unterschied gemacht haben. Also nicht ich jetzt selbst, sondern irgendjemand, was weiß ich, hier Raul ist doch wirklich das beste Beispiel. Der hat da einfach jeden Preis verdient. Am besten noch dotiert, wenn es ein Stück Blech vom Bundespräsidenten ist und der Staat sozusagen anerkennt, dass hier soziale Basisarbeit einfach eine wertvolle Sache ist. Dann finde ich das auch in Ordnung.
Sag mal, der Raul, das Ding eigentlich, das war doch zu Zeiten von... Wie hieß der noch?
Der Vogel.
Nein, das war jetzt vor kurzem erst.
Ach so, der hat das von Gauck bekommen? Okay, weil der hat ja dann Turgier längere Zeit auch noch den Mangel, dass du das entweder von Köhler oder von diesem... Wie hieß der denn?
Haben wir alle schon wieder vergessen.
Genau, von dem unaussprechlichen bekommen. Okay, jetzt gleiten wir wirklich ab.
Der hat das im Verliehen...
Interessant.
Da war doch irgendwas.
Also Verliehen bekommen, also der Akt der Verleihung wurde durchgeführt von Ursula von...
Und spätestens da muss man dann wirklich sagen. Da wiederum muss ich sagen, also da kann man entweder sagen, ich nehm das nicht an oder man sagt, so, durch das tue ich der Frau jetzt ein und danach machen wir noch eine Runde Smalltalk-Uhrsalat. Dann unterhalten wir uns noch ein bisschen.
Ja, man könnte jetzt eigentlich eher Raul Krauthausen-Preis mal ausschreiben, das wäre wahrscheinlich angemessen.
Na, lass mal immer noch ein bisschen leben, bevor wir irgendwelche Preise nach ihm nennen. Das wäre auch Vorschuss, du auch, Bernd. So, jetzt haben wir lange genug hier uns in die Tinte geritten. Jetzt haben wir schon die anti-Deutschen und die anti-IMS und die Bundesverdienst-Kreuzträger. Und die Friedensnobel-Preisträger natürlich auch.
Die CDU-Wähler.
Haben wir CDU-Wähler unter den Hörern? Nee, ich glaub nicht.
Das kann immer passieren, also ich meine das, warum nicht?
Ich hab nicht so viele CDU-Wähler. Einige meiner besten Freunde sind CDU-Wähler. Da siehst du mal. Zu den Wahlen kommen wir nachher. Wir haben noch ein kleines Thema in unserer traurigen Zeit.
Genau, kommen wir mal zu Deutschland. Da haben wir ja auch neue Initiativen, die Überwachung zumindest im Rahmen des Zulässigen auszudehnen.
Wer sind die beiden, die sich bei der Piratenpartei um die Bestandsdatenauskunft kümmern? Wenn ich mich jetzt spontan nicht täusche, sind das Patrick Breyer und Katharina Nocun. Die beiden haben sich von der BNetz A mal erklären lassen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die BNetz A Ihnen das gegeben hat. Also die Bundesnetzagentur oder ob das generell. Auf jeden Fall waren sie die Ersten, die es kommentiert und veröffentlicht haben. 36,3 Millionen Abfragen nach Bestandsdaten, automatisierte Abfragen, wurden von der Bundesnetzagentur durchgeführt. Und zwar im letzten Jahr. In diesem Jahr kann es ja nicht sein. Also gehe ich davon aus, dass es im letzten Jahr war. Nee, Quatsch. Insgesamt 36 Millionen. Und im letzten Jahr waren es 7 Millionen. Diese Zahlen hat die Bundesnetzagentur herausgegeben. Und dazu auch eine schöne Grafik, wie diese Ersuchen von den Sicherheitsbehörden zunehmen und wie diese Abfragen dann stattfinden. So, jetzt gibt es bei der Bestandsdatenauskunft eine Unterscheidung. Und zwar gibt es einmal die automatische Abfrage. Das ist Paragraf 112 Telekommunikationsgesetz. Da kann die Bundesnetzagentur jederzeit automatisch Informationen aus den Kundendateien der Betreiber abrufen. Wenn diese erforderlich sind für das Verfolgen von Ordnungswidrigkeiten oder Straftaten. Das sind dann so einfache. Telefonnummer, wem gehört die denn? Und dann gibt es noch die manuelle Paragraf 113 Telekommunikationsgesetz, wo Bundesbehörden Nutzerinformationen bei Providern direkt abfragen können. Und da war diese Änderung, die wir vor einigen Wochen oder Monaten hier behandelt haben, wo es dann um die dynamischen IP-Adressen ging, die jetzt auf einmal auch Teil dieser Bestandsdaten sind, PINs, PUCs und so weiter, die dann mit richterlicher Genehmigung Passwörter auch noch abgefragt werden dürfen. Und ein Provider muss ab 10.000 Nutzern eine Schnittstelle zum automatischen Abfragen bereithalten. Jetzt sehen wir, dass diese Zahlen also in Millionen, im Bereich der zig Millionen sich befinden, wie diese Abfragen stattfinden und natürlich über die Jahre einfach nur linear schön zunehmen. Auch das ist natürlich nicht...
Na gut, wenn ich mir die Zahlen hier anschaue, dann gibt es auch eine gewisse... Also das Ersuchen der Sicherheitsbehörden steigt kontinuierlich an. Die Abfragen bei TK-Dienstanbietern. Die Unterscheidung ist mir ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so ganz klar. Da könnte man jetzt auch argumentieren, dass es seit drei Jahren stagniert, aber das ist jetzt auch einfach zu wenig Sample, um da wirklich einen Trend sicher ablesen zu können. Aber es ist trotzdem zu viel.
Also eine kontinuierliche Zunahme. Und jetzt sagt der... Also die Zahl, etwa sieben Millionen Anfragen im Jahr und bis zu 70.000 pro Tag. Und das ist natürlich einfach alle paar Sekunden. André hat das mal ausgerechnet, alle 4,5 Sekunden. Das ist nur die automatisierte.
Also 70.000 pro Tag.
Es gibt da die Verfassungsbeschwerde der Piraten, die Linken war auch noch mal. Was will man dazu noch sagen?
So sieht es in Deutschland aus.
Eine Moll-Sendung. Wenn wir sagen, so sieht es in Deutschland aus, ich hab mich mit meinem besten Freund die Tage mal darüber unterhalten, dass er in einem Monat in Deutschland gewählt wird.
Das war schon mal mehr Thema, oder?
Das war schon mal mehr Thema und es gab auch schon mal Wahlkämpfe, die ein Thema hatten, wo sich in dem Wahlkampf alles darum gedreht hat. Ja, eine Richtungsentscheidung für das Land irgendwie verbarg. Wo man sagte, so oder so. Vielleicht bilde ich mir das jetzt auch im Nachhinein nur so ein, aber es ging doch tatsächlich dann um wirkliche Grundausrichtungen in der Politik, die man emotional debattieren konnte und die die Menschen auch betroffen gemacht haben und politisiert haben. Das heißt, es gab irgendwie sowas wie Handlungsalternativen auf eine Herausforderung, der sich das Land gegenüber sieht. Es gab Überzeugungen, sogar Grundüberzeugungen, die da bei einer Rolle gespielt haben. Und wenn ich den diesjährigen Wahlkampf anschaue, sehe ich das nicht. Und was ich eher sehe, ist ein allgemeiner Konsens über die Grundrichtung. Und nur noch so eine Vertrauensfrage, wer ist jetzt der Coolere? Also die Argumente, die Menschen für oder gegen die Wahl von Per Steinbrück anführen, sind völlig unpolitisch. Also haben keinen politischen Hintergrund. Ähnlich ist es bei Angela Merkel und jemand, der aus diesem allgemeinen Konsens rausfällt und sagt, ich fordere oder ich stehe für eine grundsätzliche Änderung in irgendeinem Politikbereich. Wie die Linken zum Beispiel. Ja, es sind Demagogen, Populisten, unwählbar, irrational, unrealistisch. Und das hat sich recht allgemein manifestiert, dass man die Linke, das sind Populisten.
Und Kommunisten.
Und Kommunisten, ja. Jetzt sind sie auch noch so blöd und hängen hier in Berlin auf, der Osten wählt Rot. Ich meine, so eine bescheuertes Wahlplakat, okay, das haben sie selber gemacht.
Gibt es auch noch ein paar andere.
Die Wahlplakate sind alle bescheuert, aber das ist jetzt nichts Neues. Aber jeder, also zu diesem Populismusvorwurf würde ich noch gerne sagen, dass die parlamentarische Demokratie oder die Demokratie selber ist so, dass sie natürlich Populisten als Politiker hervorbringt. Und das auch nicht notwendigerweise schlecht, weil die sollen ja machen, was das Volk Populus...
Ja, ich finde jetzt auch an dem Punkt, das Wort Populist hat einen negativen Konnotation, die ich so eigentlich gar nicht unmittelbar nachvollziehe. Also ich kann nachvollziehen, warum es so eine negative Konnotation hat, aber ich finde nicht, dass es das im eigentlichen Wortsinne so verdient hätte. Also man denkt sich dabei, glaube ich, etwas anderes. Man denkt immer, wenn jemand als Populist bezeichnet wird, dann heißt das Rattenfänger, Menschenverführer, immer so ein bisschen Hitler im Hinterkopf, ohne das zu sagen. Und wird halt auch gerne immer so für die rechte Szene auch gemacht. Und wenn dann halt jemand wie Lafontaine oder so auf einmal auch Populist ist, weil er ja mal sagt, was das Volk denkt, ich meine, das wäre ja mal schön, wenn mal ein Politiker sagt, was vielleicht wirklich gedacht wird und nicht solche Phrasen.
Spannender wäre, wenn ein Politiker machen würde, was das Volk möchte. Das wäre ja noch spannender.
Ja gut, ich meine, sicherlich gibt es jetzt auch nicht nur eine Meinung, dass Volk will, sondern wir haben natürlich unterschiedliche Ausgangslagen und unterschiedliche soziale Öko-Gebiete und Herkünfte und Interessen. Ganz klar, es gibt nicht eine Meinung. Es ist sehr schwierig, so einen Konsens zu machen. Bloß, was mir eher fehlt, ist, dass auch niemand wirklich wagt, auch mal einen Zukunftsentwurf zu formulieren. Ich wünsche mir ein Deutschland, ein Europa, eine Welt, was in diese Richtung geht. Aber ich glaube, dass sie auch da vor allem eine höllische Angst haben.
Ich hab in der letzten Sendung ja schon den Begriff Postdemokratie verwendet.
Das Festlegen an sich ist schon schwierig. Deswegen legt sich auch Angela Merkel nie auf irgendwas fest. Das sind immer nur so Phrasen. Auch diese Plakate sind alle so, mehr für Familien. Bullshit.
Mehr was.
Mehr Verarschung oder mehr was?
Da wird so ein grober, allgemeiner Wert angesprochen, dem niemand widersprechen wird. Gut jetzt, im Detail verbirgt sich dann dahinter, was die CDU jetzt Familie nennt, ist natürlich dann auch die verheiratete Familie. Dann kann man noch irgendwie nachher Glaubenskämpfe darüber führen, ob man Homosexuellen im 21. Jahrhundert das zubilligt, dass sie auch eine Familie gründen, wobei das doch eh am Ende nur darum noch geht, ob das jetzt steuerliche Vorteile genießt oder nicht. Das ist auf jeden Fall der Begriff der Postdemokratie. Geht es auf Colin Crouch zurück, der sagt, ein Gemeinwesen, in dem zwar nach wie vor Wahlen abgehalten werden, in dem allerdings konkurrierende Teams professioneller PR-Experten die öffentliche Debatte während des Wahlkampfes so kontrollieren, dass sie zu einem reinen Spektakel verkommt, in dem man nur über eine Reihe von Problemen diskutiert, die Experten zuvor ausgewählt haben. Und selbst dieses über Probleme diskutieren ist inzwischen irgendwie weg. Also ein Wahlkampf ist heute ein durchorchestrierter Wettkampf von PR-Strategen, die irgendwie versuchen, ein Gefühl dafür zu erlangen, wie man irgendwie diesem Volk noch Emotionen entlocken kann, um dann für einen bestimmten Vertreter oder für eine bestimmte Partei aktiv zu werden. Es geht nicht mehr darum, das sieht man glaube ich im heutigen Wahlkampf ganz besonders, für eine wirkliche Überzeugung einzustehen. Ich bin Politiker, weil ich an etwas glaube, weil ich diese Welt verändern möchte. Ich bin Politiker, der für Überzeugungen steht. Ich bin Politiker, der für diese Überzeugungen bereit ist, stehend zu sterben, sich abwählen zu lassen, sich ein Misstrauensvotum auszusetzen und sich weiß ich von mir aus dem Parlament gegenüber geschlagen zu geben und dort zu stehen zu sagen, ok, ihr setzt mich jetzt hier ab, aber das sind Überzeugungen, die ich habe, für die ich gewählt wurde, für die ich kämpfe, für die ich diese Sache hier mache, weil ich glaube, dass das das Richtige ist. Das gibt's nicht mehr. Und es gibt auch überhaupt nicht mehr solche Überzeugungen. Als du die Brand-Wundeskanzler war, hatte Mutti noch volles Haar.
Ich glaube, da idealisiert man jetzt auch wieder so eine Vergangenheit, die es damals auch so nicht gab. In der auch irgendwie immer alles besser war. Das ist aber auch alles Augenwischerei. Das ist sehr schwierig. Ich kann, wenn ich mir bestimmte Aspekte anschaue, in der Vergangenheit auch sehr wohl Verbesserungen feststellen. So will man dann auch nicht mehr miteinander reden, wie damals gepoltert wurde. Und was das teilweise noch so für erniedrigende Züge hatte, was bestimmte Minderheiten bezüglich. Da ist man halt jetzt offener. Ich meine, die Piratenpartei kann halt so ein Vater-Vater-Kind-Plakat da plakatieren. Das regt jetzt keinen mehr auf. Das ist tatsächlich Anregung zur politischen Diskussion. Das wäre vor 20, 30 Jahren wahrscheinlich auch noch eher im Bereich total skandal gelaufen.
Ja, das ist richtig. Das ist eine Entwicklung in dieser Gesellschaft, dass die politische und gesellschaftliche Kultur assimiliert immer mehr. Das ist auch gut so, dass sie immer mehr zulässt. Immer toleranter wird und immer mehr aufnimmt. Wie gesagt, endlich haben wir eine annähernde gesetzliche Gleichbehandlung von Homosexuellen im 21. Jahrhundert erreicht. Da können wir jetzt echt mal stolz sein. Ein bisschen spät alles so.
Da ist noch einiges zu tun.
Aber wir haben da jetzt mal was. Das ist jetzt auch ein Damm, der gefallen ist. Da kann man sich jetzt mal ausbreiten und kann für Freiheit und Gleichbehandlung von Menschen sagen. Insgesamt aber, was Grundfragen des Systems wie wollen wir Leben angeht, haben wir keine Auseinandersetzungen mehr. Ich hatte das schon vor einigen Folgen mal angesprochen, wie die zentrale Ausrichtung, wollen wir eine Sozialstadt sein oder nicht, wie wollen wir diesen Sozialstaat gestalten. Da wurden vor ein paar Jahren Entscheidungen getroffen, die richtig richtungsweisend waren. Zwar in einer Richtung, die ich jetzt nicht gut heiße.
Also meinst du jetzt Hartz IV und ähnliche Sachen.
Wir führen einen Arbeitszwang ein. Und nehmen den Menschen den Schutz des Sozialstaats weg. Kurz zur Erinnerung, Sozialstaat schützt die Menschen vor der Ausbeutung, weil er den Menschen das Recht oder die Möglichkeit gibt, der Abhängigkeit von dem Arbeitgeber zu entkommen. Ich sitze als Arbeitnehmer auf dem Arbeitsmarkt, der ja kein wirklicher Markt ist, aber ich sitze quasi als Ware auf dem Arbeitsmarkt, die der Arbeitgeber kaufen soll. Und wenn er mich heute nicht kauft, dann sitze ich abends ohne Geld da und der Arbeitgeber mit Geld. Weil er das Geld nicht ausgegeben hat. Der kann sein Geld lagern, das gibt sogar Zinsen und wird mehr. Und ich kann nur eine bestimmte Zeit ohne, dass ich arbeite, überleben in diesem System. Deswegen gibt es dann den Sozialstaat, der mir zumindest die Baseline sichert und sagt, selbst wenn ich nicht arbeite, muss ich mich zwar im Verzicht üben, aber ich muss nicht um meine Existenz fürchten. Das heißt, ich habe auch unter natürlich Einschränkungen die Möglichkeit, jeden Tag meinem Arbeitgeber gegenüber zu treten und zu sagen, das mache ich nicht und ich gehe woanders hin oder ich arbeite lieber gar nicht. Und diese Kraft, das ist der einzige Grund, warum du wirklich einen Sozialstaat haben willst. Damit du irgendwie dem Kapitalismus da eine Grenze setzt, dass nicht wieder alle als Sklaven in den Kohlen Minen verrecken. Okay, jetzt diskutieren wir hier über Sozialstaat. Aber das gibt es in Deutschland jetzt nicht mehr.
Ich sehe da auch noch ein paar andere Motivationen. Na gut, ich meine in gewisser Hinsicht hat sich ja zum Beispiel diese ganze Debatte um das Grundeinkommen oder insbesondere das bedingungslose Grundeinkommen eher verstärkt. Ich sehe da noch lange keinen gesamtgesellschaftlichen Durchbruch, aber es ist jetzt auch schon so ein bisschen aus dem Schatten getreten. Also man merkt, dass das jetzt, sagen wir mal, eins dieser diskutierfähigen Grundideen zu sein scheint, zumindest für weite Teile einer links geprägten Politisierungsgruppe. Und ja, im Ergebnis ist das immer noch mal eine andere Sache, aber es wird zumindest geführt und das ist natürlich auch eine Reaktion auf die Ergebnisse dieser Erinnerung. Aber ich frage mich jetzt gerade, warum du eigentlich bei Logbuch Netzpolitik auf die Ebene jetzt hinaus siehst, oder eine Verbindung, oder trennen wir uns jetzt einfach mal vom Digitalien?
Also worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte ist, also jetzt Sozialstaat ist eine Sache, die mich irgendwie beschäftigt, weil ich Arbeitnehmer bin und ich wäre gerne, also ich sehe...
Du würdest es einfach gerne thematisiert sehen im Wahlkampf.
Ich sehe das gerne thematisiert. Ich nehme das jetzt als Beispiel für eine Richtungsentscheidung, die gefallen wurde, die nach ein paar Jahren niemand mehr ernsthaft in Frage stellt. Da wurde einfach eine große Errungenschaft abgebaut, die ist jetzt erledigt. Wir haben jetzt die Leute sitzen da und das hat sich jetzt durchgesetzt. Da haben wir eine hohe Errungenschaft der Demokratie in ein paar Jahren einfach abgebaut und da kräht nachher kein Hahn mehr nach. Und genau diese Entwicklung steht natürlich in der Netzpolitik nun auch bevor. Es gab jetzt diese schöne oder es gab auch in diesen Wochen die Nachricht, dass jetzt irgendwie Mark Zuckerberg hingegangen ist, irgendwie so eine NGO gegründet hat oder eine Stiftung, die irgendwie dafür sorgen soll, dass überall Internet ist, weil irgendwie noch zwei Drittel der Menschheit noch gar kein Internet haben. Und das interessante Netzpolitisch finde ich jetzt, dass wir quasi das Internet jetzt schon diese große gesellschaftliche Bedeutung hat. Wir jetzt schon die Kriege und Kämpfe führen darum, wie dieses Netz gestaltet sein soll in Zukunft. Und diese Kämpfe, die wir jetzt verlieren als netzpolitische Bewegung, ob national oder international, die werden wir, wenn wir sie einmal verloren haben, so schnell gar nicht wieder kämpfen können. Und da kommt diese gesamte Entwicklung, wie das politische System, die politischen Systeme eben funktionieren, dass da Sachen ausgehöhlt werden. Und dann eben, dann sind sie faktisch, dann sind sie normal und dann wird weiter ausgehöhlt. Und da gibt es keine, wir steuern auf so einen Abgrund zu. Und wenn wir einen Kampf mal gewinnen, dann ist das so ein Etappensieg. Und dann führen wir den halben Jahr später wieder. Und das ist wirklich, ich meine, das ist eine dramatische Situation, je mehr man sich das vergegenwärtigt. Und gleichzeitig haben wir in der Gesellschaft diese Entwicklung, dass die Menschen einerseits durch die ökonomischen Zwänge, die für sie einfach immer präsenter werden, immer weniger Zeit haben, sich auch mit solchen Dingen auseinanderzusetzen. Die Menschen haben andere Sorgen, als ob jetzt ihre Facebook-Nachrichten gelesen werden oder nicht, weil sie nicht mehr die Muße haben, auf diesem hohen Niveau der Bedürfnisse einer Demokratie überhaupt zu diskutieren, weil sie schon ganz andere Bedürfnisse der Menschen für sie schwer erreichbar sind und viel Engagement und viel Zeit und viel Leid verlangen. Wie gesagt, Sicherung der eigenen Existenz. Damit sind Menschen, das ist ein großer Teil der Bevölkerung, den größten Teil seiner Zeit beschäftigt. Und man kann quasi in so einer Bedürfnispyramide, ist halt unten schon trotzdem immer nochmal, essen. Und wenn das schon irgendwie nicht klappt und du irgendwie für, dann wirst du dir um die anderen Sachen nicht mehr so viel Sorgen machen. Deswegen führen ja dann irgendwie die intellektuellen und finanziellen Eliten aus ihren Dornröschen-Schwässern dann eben theoretische Debatten über Netzneutralität. Das interessiert doch ein Hartz-IV-Empfänger nicht. Auch wenn es für, also Entschuldigung, dass ich das jetzt so sage, aber das soll jetzt keine Pauschalisierung sein, dass Hartz-IV-Empfänger sich dafür nicht interessieren. Aber die haben gerade ein sehr viel anderes, sehr viel präsenteres Problem.
Ja, wobei, ist ja so diese klassische Frage, wie kriegen wir dem, wie soll man sagen, also dem gemeinen Volk, dem normalen Gesellschaftsteilnehmer oder dem irgendwie nicht mit Netzthemen so sehr vertrauten Menschen diese Problematiken, die wir sehen in diesen Trends, vermittelt?
Das geht nicht. Ich glaube, da kann man jetzt sagen, wie kriegt man den vermittelt? Die wirkliche Antwort ist Existenzsicherung und Bildung. Genau das wird uns jetzt als nächstes genommen.
Ja, ich würde es anders formulieren. Genau, jetzt wurde, sagen wir mal, dieser Hartz-IV-Widerstand. Das nimmt ja auch durchaus zu. Ich merke, dass das einfach für weitere Unruhe sorgt, dass einfach dieses fortschreitende Ungerecht, was dort, die fortschreitende Ungerechtigkeit, die vielen Leuten dort widerfährt, sich an der Stelle jetzt mit den netzpolitischen Fragen paart. Wenn man diese Debatte führt, so na ja, okay, ihr werdet jetzt alles, was ihr schreibt bei Facebook und alles, was ihr sonst wie per E-Mail, alles, was ihr digital austauscht. Überlegt mal, was ihr alles austauscht, mit wem ihr euch alles austauscht. Und natürlich interessieren die sich nicht für eure Urlaubsbilder. Und die interessieren sich auch für diesen normalen Chit Chat überhaupt nicht. Die schneiden den Satz zwar mit und in dem Moment, wo sie feststellen, dass es nur darum geht, das interessiert die auch nicht. Weil das ja mal so diese Debatte ist so, ich mach ja nur das, ich mach ja nur das, ich mach ja nur das, da gibt es ja nichts zu verbergen. Klar, solange das so ist, sind sie auch zufrieden. Aber sei mal gegen einen Trend in dieser Gesellschaft. Sei mal dagegen, wie dir die Unterstützungsgelder gekürzt werden. Sei mal dagegen, wie es deinen Kindern auf der Schule geht. Sei mal dagegen, wie du als Mitglied irgendeiner auch nur ansatzweise erkennbaren Minderheit von einem bestimmten politischen oder gesellschaftlichen Trend ausgeschlossen wirst. In dem Moment, wo du dich dagegen erhebst, dem Moment bist du das Ziel. Und in dem Moment kannst du dich auch schon nicht mehr wehren. Ich hatte so eine Debatte vor ein paar Tagen, so auf dem Spielplatz. Und ich will nicht sagen, das ist jetzt so die Lösung dieser Debatte. Ich war aber sehr erstaunt, dass das zumindest für so ein paar Sekunden zu so einem Nachdenken geführt hat. Dass dieser Aspekt sehr wohl ist. Weil jeder spürt eigentlich irgendetwas auf dieser Ebene. Und dass die digitale Kommunikation auch Teil all dieser Themen ist. Dass es eigentlich in alles reinreicht, wo man selber schon dieses Gefühl hat, eigentlich müsste es hier mehr Widerstand geben. Warum kämpft keiner mit mir dagegen? Kann man auch sagen, ja. Wahrscheinlich weil die Leute schon längst ausgesiebt worden sind und schon mit Scheiße beworfen wurden, die nirgendswett eine Veränderung herbeiführen können.
Ich denke, es gibt dann... Also das ist sicherlich ein Teil dessen. Aber ich würde noch weitergehen mit dem, also wohin unsere Gesellschaft sich entwickelt. Und da würde ich nochmal wirklich zurückgehen zu diesem, es werden keine Alternativen mehr diskutiert. Es wird alles irgendwie assimiliert. Und es wird dadurch gleichzeitig die Wahrheit als dieses System manifestiert. Es werden nicht mehr Entscheidungen in ihrem Grundsatz in Frage gestellt. Von keiner der beiden Volksparteien. Und du hast quasi dieses festgefahrene System, was sich irgendwie durch eigene Trägheit am Laufen hält. Du hattest vorhin ein paar Ausgaben auch mal gesagt, ja, Obama kommt da hin, aber die US-Regierung ist halt ein großer Tanker. Und da reißt du halt nicht einfach mal der Steuer um. Und wenn du überhaupt erstmal auf den Steuerstand von dem Tanker kommst, dann hast du schon lang genug mitgemacht, um zu wissen, dass dieser Tanker geradeaus fährt. Ich sehe das aber auch in den Jugendkulturen. Also ich würde die These mal ausstellen, du hattest früher Punks und Skins, Hippies, Rocker, die hatten immer einen konkreten Aspekt der Gesellschaft, den sie radikal abgelehnt haben, und wozu sie einen Gegenentwurf entwickelt haben. Das waren immer, die waren, ob sie wollten oder nicht, waren diese Jugendkulturen politische Statements und Gruppierungen. Das war nicht alles politisiert, aber allein ihr Handeln, allein das, was sie da gemacht haben, hatte eine politische Bedeutung, hatte auch wahrscheinlich seine Basis in dem, wie die Gesellschaft jetzt ist. Heute, gut jetzt wohne ich hier in Berlin, und in Berlin hast du jetzt gerade das Problem, dass das alles irgendwie depressive Hipster sind. Hipster, ganz einfach, assimiliert einfach jede Jugendkultur auf der steten Suche, dass es irgendwie was individuelles, einzigartiges, neuartiges gibt. Das ist eigentlich das Problem, worunter diese Hipster-Jugendkultur leidet, dass sie sich nicht mehr individualisieren kann in dieser Gesellschaft, die alles assimiliert. Ich meine, es reicht halt heute nicht mehr, dir irgendwie die Haare zum Iro zu schneiden, zu färben und dir einen Ring in der Lippe zu hängen. Da konntest du in 80er Jahren... Ja, sogar ohne Ring. In 80er Jahren konntest du damit echt noch ein Statement machen und dir selber auch eine Identität geben. Und das ist heute nicht mehr möglich. Die sind heute auf der Suche irgendwie nach dem Unbekannten, dem Vergessenen und vor allem dem, was durch andere abgelehnt wird. Das finden sie aber nicht mehr. Also der Hipster rennt da rum und muss irgendwelche alten Platten suchen. Aber wenn das irgendwie eine Band ist, die irgendjemand anders kennt, ist das ja schon scheiße. Weil der kennt die ja. Und der findet die vielleicht sogar auch noch gut. Du kannst nicht mehr, du findest heute nichts mehr, wo du wirklich dich individualisieren kannst. Wo du einfach sagen kannst, ich bin Punk und das stiftet mir eine Identität. Und da gibt es Leute, die lehnen das ab. Und das ist der Feind. Aber die meisten, also was ich jetzt so sehe, gut jetzt ist meine Arbeitsstelle auch irgendwie in Berlin Mitte, da muss ich mir das Elend jeden Tag angucken. Also es ist irgendwie so, es ist irgendwie so alles egal. Wir sind wirklich in dieser poststrukturalistischen Welt angekommen, wo den Leuten auch klar ist, die Abgrenzungen, die wir ziehen, sind arbitrier und sie sind im Prinzip auch egal. Und das ist eigentlich eine tolle Erkenntnis. Aber diese Depression und Lethargie und diese nicht erfolgende oder diese nicht befriedigende Suche nach einer Identität und nach Werten, die finde ich spiegelt sich sehr stark in diesen Gruppen wider. Und ich weiß nicht, was passieren muss und wird, damit sich irgendwie halt etwas wirklich ändert. Und dieser Tanker überhaupt noch mal, ich mein, ich fänd's ja schon schön, wenn man aus dem Tanker jetzt ein Flugzeug bauen würde, was in eine andere Richtung fliegt oder so. Aber das wird alles nicht passieren. Und verstehst du, was soll aus dieser Gesellschaft werden? In welche Richtung entwickeln wir uns? Und wie kann das irgendwie noch mal zum Besseren werden? Oder ist das vielleicht auch das Gute? Vielleicht ist das ja toll. Vielleicht ist das der Frieden, in den sich alle, in die Richtung des Friedens, in die sich jetzt alle bewegen.
Ich glaub, so den Eindruck für diese Debatte sollten wir uns für die nächste Sendung mal Verstärkung einkaufen.
Ja, wir brauchen den Gregor.
Aber ich...
Und das ist halt wirklich... Aber ich muss nochmal betonen, weil mich das echt gerade so beschäftigt. Wir leben in dieser tollen Demokratie. Und die hat sich... Ja, das ist jetzt auch noch keine neue Entwicklung, keine alte Entwicklung. Na doch, eigentlich schon. Die Idee ist, alte Demokratie, aber es ist jetzt noch nicht lange, dass die Demokratie wirklich so realisiert ist. Und allein in Deutschland innerhalb von wenigen Dekaden sind wir dabei, dass das ein... Ja, dass das ungefähr den gleichen Einfluss hat, wie das Könighaus in Großbritannien. Da passiert halt nichts mehr. Da wird gewunken, da wird toll gefunden, die Menschen sind...
Ja gut, ich meine, vielleicht muss man auch erstmal akzeptieren, dass unsere Wahrnehmung einfach noch nicht ausreichend populär ist. Vielleicht auch nie wird. Also es ist einfach... Es ist einfach eine kleine Gruppe, die sieht das so und der Rest denkt sich nur so, oh, so ist doch nett.
Das ist okay, die Leute müssen nicht unbedingt meine Überzeugung haben. Die können auch... Okay, jetzt bin ich vorsichtig in Anbetracht dessen, was gerade in Marzahn-Hellersdorf passiert. Aber sag ich mal, grundsätzlich wäre das schon für eine Demokratie erstrebenswert, dass die Menschen sich mit politischen Handlungsalternativen auseinandersetzen und da aufgrund rationaler Überlegungen oder vielleicht auch einfach nur im Rahmen eines Klassenkampfes Interessen entwickeln.
Ja, es könnte ja sein, dass es da Leute gibt, die dann vielleicht einfach so durch ihre ganze digitale Prägung anfangen, eine eigene Partei zu gründen. Hoppala, hatten wir gerade.
Ja, genau. Und was ist passiert? Die wurden innerhalb von ein paar Jahren so dermaßen reinassimiliert, dass alles, was noch Alleinstellungsmerkmal ist, jetzt nämlich erfolgreich als Utopie und unrealistisch gelten kann. Die Piraten sind da nicht anders dran als die Linkspartei. Das war vorher zu sehen wie nur was, dass die Piraten kommen. Dann wird eine Zeit lang, wird das alles auf Spiegel Online gehypt. Guck mal hier, die neuen hier im Big Brother-Container. Und dann hat man die irgendwann durchgelutscht und dann ist Feierabend und dann ist da nichts mehr drin. Tobi, mit dem ich mich unterhalten habe, da fiel eben dieser schöne Satz, der sagte, ähm, was hat er gesagt? Da hab ich gedacht, das ist die Zukunft. Piraten und Liquid Ecstasy. Und da reden wir inzwischen schon von einem Stück Brot dabei. Da reden wir jetzt schon von einem damals. Und das ist noch nicht lange her. Wie lange unser politisches System in seiner Stabilität gebraucht hat, um so eine Gruppe junger, motivierter Menschen im Prinzip an sich zerschellen zu lassen.
Ja, das ist jetzt auch schon so ein bisschen... Ich lasse jetzt mal die ganzen historischen Vergleiche auf jeden Fall. Ob das nicht im Wesentlichen selbstverschuldet ist, das will ich jetzt mal dahingestellt wissen. Das ist auch wirklich... Das ist so eine Mördertheorie mit irgendwie, oh Gott, wir sind jetzt gemäuchelt worden. Das System, wie das schon klingt, ist überhaupt ein schwieriges, ganz andere Debatte. Von Systemen zu sprechen, finde ich immer sehr schwierig, weil das setzt so ein bisschen voraus, dass die alle koordiniert handeln und irgendwie so eine ganz klare Systematik existiert, nach der eine nennenswert große Gruppe zielgerichtet und vielleicht sogar angeführt handelt.
So meine ich nicht den Begriff des Systems. Ich würde sagen, damit meine ich, es ist gut, dass du das ansprichst, weil ich weiß, was die Konnotation da ist.
Das ist auch so im verschwörungstheoretischen Bereich ein sehr beliebtes Wort.
Wenn ich von einem System spreche, dann spreche ich von einer Kombination aus Anreizen für Menschen. Aus Anreizen und von mir aus teilweise eben auch Zwingen. Aber Zwinge gibt es ja gar nicht mehr so viele. Aber du hast quasi der Handlungsanreiz für einen Politiker im Parlament. Welche Möglichkeiten hat der? Welche Eigenschaften muss der haben, um überhaupt in diesem System, System, Parlament, eine Position zu bekommen? Denke an so Dinge wie Fraktionszwang. Du steigst in so eine Partei ein, da musst du das Vertrauen der Menschen gewinnen. Und du musst dann irgendwie in deinem Wahlkreis das Vertrauen der Menschen gewinnen. Das heißt, wenn du nicht die Gabe hast, Menschen mit einer Rede zu begeistern, dann wirst du in diesem parlamentarischen System keinen Erfolg haben. Du kannst tolle Ideen haben, du kannst eventuell der Berater von jemandem werden, der da irgendwie sein Fähnchen in den Wind hält. Aber es gibt einfach bestimmte Persönlichkeits-Eigenschaften, die eine bestimmte Tätigkeit geradezu verlangt. Und die es dir unmöglich machen, wenn du sie nicht hast. Oder nur sehr schwer möglich machen.
Wie kriegst du jetzt den Dreh zum Niedergang der Piratenpartei? Das bin ich jetzt mal gespannt. Du hast zwei Minuten.
Wieso habe ich nur zwei Minuten?
Wir diskutieren hier schon viel zu lange über das Thema.
Die Piratenpartei ist mit einem neuen Ansatz an Politik in ein politisches System geraten, das bestimmte Ansprüche in der Berichterstattung, in der Transparenz und in der Intransparenz an ihre Akteure richtet. Und was die Piraten am Ende in ihre jetzige Position gebracht hat, war ihre Transparenz, die in dem parlamentarischen, Medien- und sonst was System, in das sie da eindringen wollten, ihnen mehr geschadet als genutzt hat. Und zwar haben sie insbesondere über ihre internen Prozesse Transparenz geführt, die dann relativ einfach von den Medien boulevardisiert werden konnten. Und sie haben somit jegliche politische Glaubwürdigkeit oder viel von ihrer politischen Glaubwürdigkeit eingebüßt, weil nicht jeder einzelne ihrer Mitglieder den Intellekt und die Geradlinigkeit eines Martin Delios hat. Und das ist auch ein zu erwartender Effekt gewesen.
Ja gut, in der CDU hat sicherlich auch nicht jeder unbedingt den Intellekt und die Geradlinigkeit von halbwegs ansehbaren CDU-Politikern, die jetzt im Mittelpunkt stehen.
Die ziehen auf eine andere Wählerschicht.
Also ich wäre jetzt dafür, weil wir sind schon so weit entfernt von unseren Kernthemen. Vielleicht nur noch als Gegenrede. Ich denke, dass das im Wesentlichen eine selbstverschuldete Geschichte ist. Und dieses Versprechen mit, wir haben da ein Modell. Ich glaube, dass innerhalb der Piratenpartei einfach nicht klar ist, was dieses Modell eigentlich sein soll. Es ist nicht klar, wie ihre so großgefeierte innerparteiliche Demokratie real sein soll. Tatsächlich sind sie de facto derzeit die undemokratischste Partei überhaupt, weil sie einfach nur Beschlüsse fassen kann in irgendwelchen Bergkäfern, wo Leute gerade mal ein Wochenende Zeit haben, dann über alles abzustimmen. Dazwischen gibt es nichts. Es gibt keine Delegierten. Es gibt keinerlei Beteiligungsmodell verbindlich etc., weil sich diese ganze Liquid-Sache nicht durchgesetzt hat. Und so ist es sozusagen noch katastrophaler als bei den anderen Parteien auch. Also an der Stelle, das muss man ihnen da glaube ich klar zum Vorwurf machen. Also das ist einfach zu früh alles gewesen. Von daher ist jetzt, sagen wir mal, das absehbare Scheitern wahrscheinlich eher sinnvoll, um da einfach dann auch neue Widerstandskräfte zu wecken.
So sehe ich das.
Du könntest das mal so offen lassen.
Du zwingst mich das jetzt so offen zu lassen.
Nö, ich zwinge dich zu gar nichts.
Also mir geht es in diesem Abschnitt der Sendung hauptsächlich mal überhaupt erstmal um die Gesamtsituation. Um die Diagnose der Gesamtsituation. Und das System, parlamentarische Demokratie mit seinen Anreizen, schleift sich jetzt so ein. Und die Anreize und die Inhalte sind nicht mehr genuin politischer Kultur, politischer Natur. Und das ist jetzt ein sich selbst verwaltendes System, wo man irgendwie Personal austauscht. Das ist so ähnlich wie ein Konzern. Da kannst du deine neue Konzernspitze reinstellen. Der wird eventuell einige Entscheidungen anders treffen. Und vielleicht steigt dann der Umsatz oder er sinkt. Aber am Ende stellt die immer noch Panzer her.
Ja, da gehe ich dann auch wieder um mit dem Mit.
Das war's.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Tschüss.